[Music]
it's official Pretty Little Liars is
getting a spinoff freeform greenlit a
pilot Kohl's Pretty Little Liars the
perfectionist it stars Janel Parrish and
Sasha Pieterse AX 2018 right the
potential show is based on the book
series the perfectionist by Sara Shepard
who also wrote the PLL bucks it's not
set in Rosewood but rather beacon
heights eg asked Marlene King and Sasha
about a perfectionist spin-off back in
June people think that the perfectionist
could tie in somehow with a Pretty
Little Liars spin-off can you speak to
that could be in the same universe or
feel like a similar universe mm-hmm
would any of the characters like Ali it
could be okay I would love to be honest
about everything I saw Sarah last week
she was out here we had dinner and we
talked a lot about the book and just
about things she's doing or things I'm
doing and working together and here's
what Sasha and co-star Shay Mitchell
I've hinted recently I do have to ask
you because all your fans want to know
if there's an update on a PLL spin-off
or a movie of any sort I have to be
tight lipped on that one not a no but
yes a lot of things up my sleeve Pretty
Little Liars spin-off update do you have
one to share with me I mean anything is
possible in Rosewood right
no word on which other PLL cast members
will make appearances but we think it's
a safe bet they will
[Music]
you